das war doch diese mega behinderte
geschichte ich weiß ich kann ja nur mal
eben kurz erzählen weil ganz viele
wissen als wahrscheinlich und nicht mehr
ich weiß auch nicht und zwar so auch
nicht
violetta was geht hier ist euer ghani
und wir befinden uns gerade in der team-
oldie und wir werden heute ein
zweierteam turnier zusammen mit in dem
justin hallo spielen und zwar um uns auf
das warum treten nicht aufs training
es waren für ungerade anzahl und die
gastgeber sind damit erstmals mit dabei
nice one automatisch weiter aus so ist
es okay kein keinen platz mehr am
spanier ist leider die erste folge
aussetzen
das war so unglaublich cool die erste
folge dann im spawn starten also in der
zweiten das wäre richtig um harrys von
random irgendwo dann auf der zweiten
aber dann könne man in ersten examen
ja ich habe schlechte schlechte
erfahrung mit der ersten folge war einst
auch neda war dass diese lava falle die
verboten weil ich gebaut habe
das war doch diese mega behinderte
geschichte verlassen ich kann hier noch
mal eben kurz erzählen weil ganz viele
wissen das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
ich weiß auch nicht und zwar du auch
nicht und zwar hatte das war ziemlich
ziemlich wer also echt eine mega krasse
geschichte und zwar hat mich dann
während waro plötzlich jemand geänderten
der haushalt simon punkt und dann der
nachname von von simon werle also der
richtige nachname so alles richtige
daten sogar die straße und sowas wohnort
hat alles gestimmt
jaja das stand alles da drin und ich
dachte ich okay das wird stimmt da hab
ich den angenommen der hat mir hat
einfach nicht mehr viel geschrieben und
der pfarrer max ich endlich mal wegen
barroso eine wand ein fähiger so hat
sich im nachhinein herausgestellt
und da sieht man damals noch die
projektleitung hat nicht ge ti habe ich
ich dachte mir okay was können wir
machen coole tricks um halt leute raus
fliegen zu lassen und hatte ich diese
war diese lava falls ihnen das du halt
form vor und hinter dem portal lava
platziert und wenn du jemanden ärger
geht ist er direktor quasi weil er kann
nicht rausgehen kann wasser platzieren
und er ist direktor zu und dann dachte
mir okay das ja vor die kasse für die
trasse fallen soll
genau unser entstand halt so in der im
regelwerk stand auch grauzone
und dann hab ich halt diesen mit denen
ich für für simon gehalten hab hab ich
dann stehen da wie schaut es aus ist wo
er ist so was von legend dass man das
machen
und er schreibt so ja klar kann man
machen ist nicht gegen das regelwerk
show und ich mach das und fliegt deshalb
raus alter her hast du das auch in der
conti dann gesagt dem ja habe ich gesagt
jungs dort noch kein unterschied also
nicht sieht man aber andere menschen ja
das auch mitbekommen vor kraft
eigentlich ein alter ja und sie mich
nach ausführung deshalb wünsche ich mir
dass ich in einem fairen kampf
falls ich rausfliegen sollte in diesem
war aus fliege ja ja ich bin ja auch
wegen einem hinterhalt von dem alter der
nicht mehr kämpfen wollte auf den wie im
juni
das sind nicht gesehen ich habe es ihm
meldet normal fahren gehen oder zu einer
platte in die lava gefallen
bei eur 12 nicht so wenn du dich so
wollten so carmen gehen hatten next
direkt auf die höher sind so drauf
das fängt erst der kampf gegangen
hier sind hier steht das war schlecht du
willst du denn ich komme da nicht hin
wald oder wasser gesetzt
egal was allein ich bin aber ich bin
nach comcom justine kommt ab 1
ich hab noch keinen schein bekommt
aufschlag aber ich habe den bruder jetzt
gegeben
also herr jetzt habe ich nur noch einen
schwer timo ja geht ja shit to gather
alter ich habe da nur schwer was ist ein
großer nachteil bitte kein feuer kein
wasser einmal keinen bogen
juni an wenn du okay gehen wir zusammen
auf den pinguin ich mag einfach
irgendwie drauf
übrigens fertigen scheint das können wir
uns leider auch nicht pusten okay wir
haben's alter perfekt das krass
erschlagen wollte wie das bei mir war
ich weiß jetzt dass gesehen hat oder
nicht auf jeden fall wir wollten eine
fahne gehen dann auf die höhe haben
unsere kids schlagen wollten gerade
schritt meine mama hat den also kommen
wir zum sport camp nicht so hier meint
es ernst
ja ich meine es ernst ja also wir
könnten jetzt kommen wenn ihr bock hätte
wir dachten solche halter gegendemo
könnten warum nicht sonne
wir dachten ja geben so circa ähnliches
erklärt wie wir den er ist glaube ich
nicht mal so gut wie wäre dann wie soja
okay wir kommen also ja wie auch habt
ihr danach noch eine folge zum aufnehmen
also könnt ihr noch ein volk aufnehmen
wir so ja ok dann lasst diese verrückten
gehen nächste folge kämpfen alles klar
wir gehen dahin den er nicht da dachte
man karten nicht folge wir locken uns
wieder ein nächste folge sowieso den er
kommt jetzt also ja hier und haben wir
gerade einiges gefunden
wir kommen gegen ende der folge hoch ich
dachte einfach unser alter kommen jetzt
komm einfach und den soja wird leider
doch nicht ich hab da noch ins camp
beschrieben alter kommen jetzt wir
inzwischen der zwischen den beiden
folgen
ja wir haben halt echten einiges
gefunden und sondern danach
der ngg alter so wenn ein server war
motto und zombie und die haben natürlich
alles im chat mit gelesen sind
angekommen und haben uns ein bisschen
regen
ich bin halt trotzdem alleine jetzt ja
das ist ein wahrer nächster kommt aber
das sagt kuhl erzähl mir einfach mal so
was bisher so schief gelaufen ist er
aber ich sollte nicht hochheben halt
ergibt natürlich von liebe es wenn jetzt
ein bisschen auseinander
hut ab ein eiskalter habe ich gerade
hier alles special wie viele herzen
zweieinhalb hatte ich noch oder so hab
ich natürlich seine pfeile was sich
natürlich sehen lassen kann
er kennt jetzt an der mitte okay
es kämpfen sondern das machen wieso
kämpfen natürlich könnte also sein
teamkamerad ja mehr oder weniger im
stich gelassen gerade noch 20 sekunden
in der mitte ist alles im blick
ich hab ja
der unternehmer sind rund dreieinhalb
herzen aber gut gefightet
diesmal lassen wir uns nicht schön
andere karte auf jeden fall ein bisschen
wasser das wir dann mit diensten können
okay wir gehen auf dem gerät kommt oder
ja okay die sind getrennt fiel kein
tropfen drauf ihr habt ihr zwei chance
gegeben
der andere der wert schon die absicht
von gleichen
okay beide ein halter seinen 1 1
markiert
schade dass wir es nicht weiter
geschafft haben aber wir wollen das ja
so halten dass wir alles hochladen
wie kommt ein bisschen ärgerlich wir
hätten uns besser besser absprechen
müssen aber diese natürlich auch am
anfang vom training und das wird sich
natürlich noch verbessern wäre
langweilig wenn wir schon als können
besser kein training besser einfach nur
das verfahren von daher das was von
heute wie sie muss man nicht mal wieder
schob er das team vorbei morgen ist das
video und bis dann